[Musique]
un proverbe africain dit il faut tout un
village pour élever un enfant et nous
sommes ardemment convaincu au collège
titan qu'il faut connaître d'où l'on
vient pour savoir où l'on 20 les
personnes âgées représentent les racines
de l'arbre les jeunes les élèves les
enfants les feuilles les bourgeons de
cet arbre connaître d'où l'on vient pour
savoir où l'on va c'est transmettre
l'histoire les cultures les histoires
pour avancer et se construire et devenir
plus tard un citoyen accompli éclairé et
épanouie dans le cadre d'un partenariat
le collège quittant les écoles du réseau
et les pâtes fabien lanave se sont
associés pour tisser des liens
intergénérationnels écrire des
biographies des résidents mener des
ateliers artistiques intergénérationnel
et partager des moments conviviaux
une aventure film et réunissant seniors
et juniors qui va permettre aux futurs
citoyens de la cité éducative de le port
de s'épanouir et de grandir
j'aurai donc au banjo poser des
questions sur votre visite allait pas
pourquoi vous avez eu l'idée de
travailler avec les preuves aux
cargaisons du projet les livres que
j'avais vu que tu dessines à lui de
faire michon rappelle minuscule dans le
programme joint terbium une dépense sur
l'autobiographie sur notre fiche de 9-2
rapport d'étape
on nous a proposé une collaboration
n'était pas le fait que les personnes
qui ne les ai pas avait vécu une vie qui
n'est pas transposable sur le dos des
êtres aussi lui alors j'ai choisi la
classe de 3e 4e
on regardait que leurs emplois du temps
je les avais shdm en dernier roi de la
prison ferme tandis fait de les avoir
sur les amène à libin de 6 environ
elle était le projet qu'on l'avait
orienté alors pas de gauche
les deux d'offrir aux élèves imposer son
unité de revenir donnèrent événement
marquant dans la vie il ya des cas on a
parlé elle a vu avec théâtre n'est
qu'hier des méthodes aussi que si on
avait l'idée de faire une première
rencontre avant de commenter le projet
pour nous raconter comment se porte la
rencontre entre les élèves et les
personnels
alors pour la première rencontre on a
donné à la rencontre la forme d'un
bouton et j'ai présenté les détails
après dans ses déplacements les
résidents et mon chien était le premier
à la fois ci elle est à la fois content
et en même temps tendent à l'intérieur
il ya des fortes issues de la pause
âgées moi je compte bien porter son
équipe arrivent dans les quinze jours de
détente sèche et des rêves avant de
marquer des points pour eux mais
plusieurs conditions
je dirais que je renouvelle l'expérience
je travaille avec lui en amont de la
rencontre avec le belém et les résidents
de manière à faire travailler un peu
plus d'empathie beaucoup de talent aussi
comment s'est passé le spectacle allait
pas que tu me racontes sur les bio
collègues et qu'on a préparé notre
affaire de tous on a marqué les fans et
on est rentrés personnellement pour moi
des mercenaires fois je veux bien mais à
l'époque c'était pas le sou comme une
image il a été bien organisée mais
précieuse qui profite du coup on a
commencé à préparer deux affaires la
talent et on a eu
[Musique]
oui
schiavone
m
qu'elle portait lors de ce moment comme
mon avis mais parce qu'on a su parer les
temps que il
d'après toi comment ont réagi les faire
c'est âgées lors de spectacles de sons
des banquiers des contents et heureux de
voir google
la photo est soudain bien je suis en
garde
on a quand même triste
on
[Musique]
la charge mon plus beau livre ou
dimanche
je
tel celui qui porte son nom
mon île de la réunion